California has got one heck of a problem
and Californians are only beginning to
wake up to that reality now how should
they be thinking good morning well
they're waking up slowly and that's part
of the mistake how should they be
thinking there are two things we're in
year four of the drought just in
California just drought my last two more
years or six more years it could last a
decade you could literally have sixth
and seventh graders with no memory of
real rain storms so part one is you need
to figure out how to make it through the
next few years the short term how to
keep business growing and thriving
California's economy has come back how
to keep the farms working half the
produce in the United States comes from
California but I think much more
important California needs to reinvent
its water system which is incredibly
elaborate and complex to account for
this kind of dryness the system that
exists doesn't work very well and they
need a long-term re-imagination and then
they need to teach the rest of us what
they learned about how to manage scarce
water
where are they going to get the money to
do this if Californians are only waking
up now to realize this is an issue
clearly budgets and laws have not yet
been passed to afford to do some sort of
revamp like you're saying well I'm not
sure money is the most important thing
it doesn't cost any money to take a
shorter shower a third of the water
utilities supply in California that's
different from the agricultural water of
course a third of the water utility
supply goes to lawn watering so it
doesn't cost any money to stop watering
your lawn it does cost money to
substitute better landscaping in the in
the short term but the truth is
Stephanie it costs a lot of money to
find new water for California and so
what you really need to do is say how do
we make the water we've got economically
productive and and as economically
productive as possible so Charles why
not just put a price on it
why not
allocate an amount of water a minimum
amount of water that everybody every
California needs to survive and of
course the odd shower but not car
washing for example and not necessarily
watering your lawn and just charge
Californians for everything they consume
over and above that minimum well
that system kind of exists for the for
the utility water people the the issue
is that sixty or seventy percent of the
water in California goes to farms and
there's a very complicated
hundred-year-old system for who gets
that water whether they pay how much
they pay and when I talk about
reinventing the system that's what I'm
talking about and how you share well I
meant to charge everybody for it not
just not just well folks in Santa Cruz
or in you know out in Palm Springs of
course most of the water gets consumed
by agriculture but I've seen many
arguments and you would know better than
me whether they're accurate that the the
agricultural consumers aren't paying in
many cases a fair market price for that
water or what should be a fair market
price they aren't and and of course if
if they start paying more will start
paying more for our fruits and
vegetables but what happens if you
charge for water is people find ways of
saving it right largely free and so I'm
I'm a big fan of bringing some economics
to water the problem is that there are
laws that entitle people to water and so
when I talk about reinventing the system
you have to start with a clean sheet of
paper and then figure out who who's
gonna be hurt and how you transition
them so you can't just wave a magic wand
what I think is interesting is the jury
Brown just reelected governor at the
height of his popularity as governor and
then you talk about the CEO of Disney
the CEO of Google the CEO of Apple
Facebook Twitter the some of the most
prominent companies and some of the most
prominent communications companies in
the world all headquartered in
California there's no conversation
there's no attention to the problem from
those people you know when I'm getting
mail swimming pools at their houses just
a guess well it's it's
more than that when you press ENTER on a
Google search two tablespoons of water
is used to do that Google search every
time all the time but walk us through
that one more time two tablespoons of
water is used every time I hit enter in
a Google search house and even if you're
using it on your iPhone and you just
press GO yes because that's pretty cool
Google uses enormous quantities of water
to run its server centers Apple uses
enormous quantities of water Disney uses
enormous quantities of water Intel
actually reports all of its water use
around the world to make chips and those
people could step up and say to the
governor as could the large farm
communities and and irrigate errs we
need a conversation about how to fix the
system and they seem they seem oblivious
which is sad Charles before we run out
of time where would you where would you
have them look where in the world gets
water right what jurisdiction
municipality country tell us the
quickest the quickest place to look is
Australia Australia looks very much like
California economically and climate wise
Australia had a ten year drought across
the entire country and they had to
reinvent their water system the
economics of it they cut the amount of
water people at home used in half and
they reimagined just what you were
talking about Eric the economics of how
water is supplied to big users and and
Australia has all kinds of lessons much
closer to home Las Vegas the city of Las
Vegas has a lot to teach Sacramento Los
Angeles San Diego because Las Vegas
lives with the amount of water that was
allocated in 1935 and they're a little
bigger than they were there's lots of
lessons even very close to home one
quickly before we run Charles I've
spoken to some farmers out in the
Central Valley they constantly point a
finger at environmentalists and the
smelt for example that lives in the
Sacramento River drainage and say that
if the government didn't allocate so
much water to the fish we wouldn't have
a problem what do you say to those folks
what I said to those folks is if if
you've set up a water system that
requires extinct
fishing of species to grow our broccoli
and our strawberries the system isn't
right in the short term they may have a
reasonable argument in the long term all
that tells you is the system is broken
you're facing farmers off against the
smelt the truth is those farmers are
pumping so hard out of the ground that
in many places in California the ground
is falling an inch a month a foot a year
so the system really needs reinvention
and and rain hoping for rain is not a
plan